what is the fiercest animal you think
you could take in a fight the fierceness
is for sure I probably I'd kick a
flamingos or something
I could take a flamingo I would hope
right I think I could kick it from that
one leg out yeah I don't [__] with birds
do they go like they get to pecking at
you yeah yeah I really don't have a fear
of pit bulls like that if they latch
onto my arm I think with the adrenaline
if you give me my left I'm going Cranium
non-stop I think I could take you could
take a pit bull you think if it just
latched if it if it went nuts I'm
chilling what do you think about the
pitbulls that are like Suburban pits
like a project pit bull I don't know if
you know what a project pit bull like
they eat Pepsi cans it's on Section
Eight yeah it gets government assistance
I don't think you want to see that see
one of those one of that it only gets
dog food on the first one yeah you don't
want to see those one in that tuna Court
yeah